l'épidémie du coffee 19 ralenti les
résultats sont bons sur le plan
sanitaire conséquence il n'y a désormais
plus de départements en rouge sur la
carte de france
seul notre région l'île de france et en
orange
alors première bonne nouvelle et bien
dès ce week-end le public pourra de
nouveau accéder aux parcs et aux jardins
franciliens concernant vos déplacements
dès le 2 juin la règle des 100 km est
supprimée sur le territoire français
dans le secteur de l'éducation
maintenant 100% des écoles maternelles
et primaires ouvriront progressivement
dès mardi 2 juin l'ensemble des collèges
va rouvrir y compris dans les yvelines
qui est donc en zone orange avec dans un
premier temps elle les sixièmes et les
cinquièmes pour les lycées yvelinois la
priorité sera donnée aux établissements
professionnels et notamment aux élèves
qui doivent passer une certification
pour les lycées généraux il y aura des
convocations individuelles
enfin informations importantes l'épreuve
orale du bac de français est annulé elle
sera validée en contrôle continu
concernant maintenant les bars les cafés
les restaurants ils pourront couvrir en
zone verte elle les yvelines et en zone
orange seuls les terrasses seront
autorisés à rouvrir dès le 2 juin le 2
juin tous les musées et monuments
couvriront également sur l'ensemble du
territoire pour les parcs de loisirs les
salles de spectacle et les piscines ou
encore les salles de théâtre et bien il
faudra attendre le 22 juin dans les
yvelines pour qu'il rouvre les cinémas
heureux ouvriront leurs portes le 22
juin
mais ça ce sera sur l'ensemble du
territoire même date également 22 juin
pour l'ouverture des campings yvelinois
reste interdit les événements culturels
et sportifs dans l'espace public
l'ouverture des discothèques les stades
les hippodromes ou encore les salles de
jeux enfin un nouveau point sera fait
justement aux alentours du 22 juin pour
la phase iii du déconfinement